the baltimore ravens have a left tackle
in ronnie stanley they paid him a lot of
money last year and then he suffered a
broken leg orlando brown jr moved over
to left tackle and he decided i kind of
like it here and there's a good reason
to like it there that's how you get paid
more money as an offensive lineman in
the nfl and so this tweet came january
29 i'm a left tackle report yesterday no
surprise from nfl media brown wants out
brown wants to go somewhere where he
will be a left tackle he's entering the
final year of his contract chris
and
look at the the
the ravens uh can can easily say to him
play for us or play for no one he's got
a salary of 920 000
for next year uh
he he's shown
by playing pretty well in stanley's
absence that he can get it done but uh
you know i it's he doesn't have a whole
lot of cards here maybe he's inspired by
all these quarterbacks that are trying
to talk their way out of their current
locations but i don't know what the
ravens are going to do about this other
than say you're under contract and the
time for you to get paid is next year
not this year whether it's by us or
someone else yeah no i mean the ravens
certainly have that you know in their
court there's no doubt about that he's
he's a hell of a player it would be
a huge loss for them to to have to get
rid of orlando brown jr or do anything
like that now mike i mean i think you
bring up the right point you know one
okay
i think the guy likes playing left
tackle that's where he feels most
comfortable at that's what he's you know
and i'm trying to think back oklahoma
yeah he played left tackle that's that's
where he wants to be so there's
obviously a comfort there and and listen
there is a difference you know again hey
you know just like you know shooting a
basketball i like shooting layups you
know with this one way right you know
well the offensive lineman have those
same type of things i like coming off
the line of scrimmage and pushing a
certain way as compared to the other way
where maybe that leg's not dominant
so
comfort with the position or overall
liking of the position more at the
tackle position and then i guess like to
what you're saying right is that the
other thing you think that plays a
factor in it just sheer dollars because
there is a difference between left
tackle and right tackle why i don't
really even know at this point that's i
it honestly is kind of weird to me but
what is it right tackle lane johnson and
trent brown right lead the way at 18
million and 16 million i believe left
tackle it's a different story you got
bhaktiari and tunzo right at 23 and 22
million right around there so there is a
difference of five million dollars at a
premium as far as the top of the
position and i guess that's what he's
thinking about too
tristan worfs who was the right tackle
as a rookie for the tampa bay buccaneers
had a colorful
explanation back in uh what'd he say
let's see when this was this was in
april he said uh when i
because he actually went back and forth
at iowa from left tackle
when i started flipping back and forth i
was
oh trying to look for a big difference
honestly the only big difference is you
got your other hand down it just feels
awkward at first but once you settle in
it feels fine
it kind of feels like wiping your butt
with your other hand it's very nice very
nice yeah well i mean
yes they can make the adjustment sorry
london yeah sorry london uh they can
make the adjustment i mean orlando brown
has been a really damn good right tackle
he's perfectly capable he's just telling
you he likes left and he likes that
money and that's the big thing and hey
listen worse than orlando brown jr i'll
say this you know there were two guys
worse i didn't know if he could play
tackle in the nfl i didn't know if his
foot quickness was good enough but these
guys the one thing they've taught me
like i try to self scout myself right a
little bit when i evaluate them in the
draft they're such big human beings and
so strong
that the foot quickness is overrated
it's just overrated yeah you might kind
of get getting around the edge on him
and you think oh i'm getting around him
yeah good luck his right arm's 120
pounds and now he's pushed you and you
went seven yards past the quarterback
you didn't even come close so the foot
speed thing is very overrated orlando
brown is a tremendous force on the
offensive line and uh that's gonna be
interesting to see what happens mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports